DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM AS OF YET.
THEIR TOTAL OF FOURTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA.
WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON CONSENT
THOSE BILLS INCLUDE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB FIVE FORTY SIX ITEM
NUMBER NINE YES.
AB SEVEN FIFTY NINE ITEM NUMBER --
ELEVEN AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE A. B. TWELVE SIXTY
FIVE AN ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB --
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHT TODAY.
DON'T NEED TO SEE THAT NOW SO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AB.
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR COME ON DOWN.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING.
AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WILL ENABLE
EIGHT ONE ONE CENTERS TO FULFILL
THEIR STATUTORY MANDATE --
MANDATE TO DUTY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE BY
NOTIFYING UNDERGROUND FACILITY
OWNERS ABOUT NEARBY EXCAVATION.
WHEN AN EXCAVATOR CALLS AN EIGHT
ONE ONE CENTER THE CENTER IS --
THE CENTER IS REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE DETAILS BUT BE DIGGING
PRO -- PROJECT TO THE FACILITY
OWNERS THAT HAVE UNDERGROUND
LINES IN THE VICINITY.
THE FACILITY OWNERS WILL THEN
SEND A FIELD TECHNICIAN TO
LOCATE AND MARKETS UNDERGROUND
LINES AT THE DIG SITE USING
COLORED PAINT.
OR FLAGS TO SHOW THE LINE
LOCATIONS THE EXCAVATORS CAM
THEN YOU SAFE DIGGING PRACTICES
TO AVOID DAMAGING THE LINES.
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
SERVICES IS NOT REQUIRED TO
SHARE GIS MAP DATA WITH THE A
ONE EIGHT ONE ONE NOTIFICATION
CENTERS.
COUNTY AND STATE G. I. S.
DEPARTMENTS CREATE THE MOST
CURRENT ACTOR AND THE SORT OF
SORTIED OF GIS MAP DATA
INCLUDING ADDRESSES ROADS
PROPERTY BOUNDARIES AERIAL
PHOTOGRAPHY AT CETERA.
SO BY REQUIRING A ONE ONE
CENTERS RECEIVE THE MOST CURRENT
GIS MAP DATA MAPPING DATA.
AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WILL BENEFIT
ALL STAKEHOLDERS BY PREVENTING
DAMAGE TO UNDERGROUND LINES I
WILL HAVE MY WITNESS -- SELF
INTRODUCE.
PLEASE HELLO I'M JAMES WINGATE
FROM USA NORTH -- EIGHT ONE ONE
WILL WHERE THE CALL BUT I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
AND WE ARE THE CENTER TO CALL
BEFORE YOU DIG OR KIND OF LIKE
DISPATCH FOR THE UTILITY
COMPANIES IT'S KIND OF LIKE HOW.
NINE ONE ONE DETERMINES WHO HAS
JURISDICTION FOR POLICE FIRE AND
MEDICAL IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY OF CERTAIN LOCATION WE
DO THE SAME THING FOR UTILITY
OWNERS WHETHER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
UTILITY OWNERS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT'S A HUGE NUMBER -- TO TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE AND AND HAVE
THEM ARRIVE AT THE DIG SITE
LOCATIONS. TO MARK THE
UNDERGROUND FACILITIES TO
PREVENT THEM FROM BEING DAMAGED.
HOWEVER A LOT OF NEW
CONSTRUCTION OCCURS -- AND
DIGGING HAPPENS IN THESE
LOCATIONS SUCH AS A NEW
RESIDENTIAL SUBDIVISION THAT'S
BEING BUILT.
AND SOLD SOMETIMES THOSE DON'T
APPEAR ON THE MAPS YET IF YOU
RELY ON A COMMERCIAL MAP
PROVIDER LIKE GOOGLE OR APPLE
MAPS OR GARMENT OR ENTITIES LIKE
THAT SO WHAT WE NEED IS THE DATA
FROM THE COUNTIES WHERE THEY
HAVE IT.
AS SOON AS IT'S BEEN APPROVED
AND SO WE WANT THE STATE TO
SHARE THAT WITH US AND WE WILL
PAY OUR SHARE OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
BUT SO THAT WE CAN BE CONSIDERED.
A SIMILAR TO A STATE AGENCY TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS -- MOST
CURRENT DATA TO USE IT AS
EFFECTIVELY AS NINE ONE ONE DOES.
OTHER WITNESSES THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER -- TODD BLOOM
SIGN FOR DICK ALERTS THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CALL CENTER --
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE DEALER
THE LAST -- FISCAL YEAR --
RECEIVED ONE MILLION REQUESTS
FOR THE SERVICE A PRODUCING
NEARLY FIVE MILLION REQUESTS TO
A UTILITY COMPANIES TO MARK
UNDERGROUND LINES OF THE SERVICE
PHOTOS SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
VOLUME WE ESCRIBO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IS SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WOULDN'T THEY COULD BE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
ASSEMBLY.
US WITH THAT WILL.
TURN -- TO THE COMMITTEE.
I I GUESS I HAVE A YOUR QUESTION --
IN IN IN NOT TO BE CONTINUALLY
OUT OUTSIDE OF THE NORMAL
COMMITTEE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT P.
JEANNIE.
BUT SHE DOES COME TO MY
ATTENTION AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
KIND OF SET ME OFF -- YEAH SO
EIGHT AGAINST THEM.
THEY'VE HAD LIKE FIVE YEARS.
OF FALSIFYING REPORTS ON THESE
TYPE OF THING SO I WONDER IF YOU
COULD SPEAK TO THAT KIND OF FILL
pTHAT WAS AND IF THERE'S A WAY
WITHIN -- THIS.
THIS PROCESS TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THOSE TYPE THINGS
DON'T HAPPEN.
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION SO RIGHT
NOW CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES THE
NOTIFICATION CENTERS US FROM
NORTH AND AND THE OTHER CALL
CENTER IN THE SOUTH TO NOTIFY
THE UTILITY OWNERS.
AND THEN THE LAW REQUIRES EACH
UTILITY OWNER TO GO LOCATED MARK
THEIR LINES IN THE FIELD.
THERE IS NO.
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT THE
FACILITY OPERATORS REPORT BACK
WHAT TYPE OF ACTION THEY DID
MEANING IF THEY MARK THE LINES
OR IF THEY SAID WE GOT OUT THERE
BUT IT TURNS OUT THAT OUR LINE
IS OVER HERE IN THE DIGGING IS
HAPPENING OVER HERE.
HOWEVER THERE IS ANOTHER BILL --
THAT I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER
RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME THAT WOULD
REQUIRE -- THE FACILITY
OPERATORS TO REPORT BACK THE
STATUS OF WOMEN A A MARKED IT
AND THEN THE EIGHT ONE ONE CALL
CENTERS WILL KEEP TRACK OF IT --
IN OUR DATABASE SO THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO PRODUCE THIRD --
NEUTRAL RECORDS OF WHEN THE
UTILITY OWNERS MARK THIS WHETHER
THEY DID ON TIME OR NOT.
SO IF THAT BILL PASSES WHICH I'M
IN SUPPORT OF PERSONALLY -- THEN
THAT WOULD.
MAKE A MECHANISM TO BE ABLE TO
REPORT THAT WERE AS WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO NOW WITH P. GINNY
FALSIFYING TAT WAS JUST THEIR
OWN INTERNAL RECORDS -- BUT THE
THEY ALSO WERE UNDER SOME
FEDERAL REGULATION BECAUSE THEY
ARE -- OPERATE TRANSMISSION
PIPELINE SO THEY WERE AUDITED BY
A FEDERAL AGENCY CALLED FILMS OF
THAT REGULATES PIPELINES AND
SELL THOSE RECORDS WERE
FALSIFIED FOR THEM IS MY
UNDERSTANDING I DON'T HAVE EXACT
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T COME TO OUR OFFICE LIKE
I SAID.
SO.
AS OF TODAY NO MECHANISM IN
PLACE TO TRACK THAT BUT IF THAT
OTHER BILL PASSES.
THE END THAT MECHANISM WOULD
BECOME ACTIVE.
WHATEVER THAT THAT LAW TAKES
EFFECT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TODD BLOOM SIGNING IN PARTICULAR
TO THAT BILLS AB ELEVEN SIXTY
SIX BY MR LEVINE.
AND IT IS IT HAS BEEN REFERRED
YOUR COMMITTEE ON THAT BILL
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO PREVENT
THE SCENARIOS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A BY PROVIDING
ELECTRONIC POSITIVE RESPONSE.
BACK TO THE CALL CENTERS. TO SO
I THINK WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS --
OFF SITE AT ONE POINT WE DID
YESTERDAY YEAH THAT'S WHAT THE
ALL RIGHT WE'LL AYE BRIDGE I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH I
GUESS WHAT ONE OTHER THING.
NOT -- TO HI JACK YOUR
PRESENTATION HERE MISTER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT IT IS THERE.
IT IS IN ALL THIS WAY TO THE
BILL COMES TO OUR COMMITTEE.
THERE'S NO OTHER OPPOSITION IF
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MISTER TURNED
SENATORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY WITH THAT -- DO WE HAVE A
QUORUM HERE YET TWO MORE WE NEED
TO MORE TO GET A QUORUM BUT WILL
TAKE IT UP -- THAT VOTE AS SOON
AS WE GET A QUORUM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE A AB TWO FORTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAHLE SOON
TO BE SENATOR DOLLY [inaudible]
RUBIO.
WE WILL TAKE A SEVEN MEMBER TEAM.
YEAH YEAH GOOD MORNING -- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- I CAME HERE.
BUT TODAY EVERYTHING AB TWO
FORTY SEVEN WHICH WILL REQUIRE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO READ
TO READ COVERED A 100% OF THE
LOCAL SHARE OF THE COST OF THE
DISASTER.
EVERY FOR THE CAR FIRE AND
SHASTA COUNTY AND THE KLAMATH ON
FIRES SISKIYOU COUNTY.
LAST YEAR WE BIRD ABOUT A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES.
WE LOST -- TO CATASTROPHIC FIRE
THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND
BUSINESSES -- WERE LOST WHICH
RESULTED IN.
HUGE LOSSES TO COUNTIES AND
CITIES -- THE FEMA PAPER. FOR A
BIG PART OF IT.
THERE'S REALLY JUST A SMALL
AMOUNT -- THAT IS THAT NEED TO
BE BACK FILLED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- WHICH HELPS -- THE FIRE
AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SERVICES
THAT THE COUNTIES AND CITIES --
REQUIRED -- TO SUPPORT FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS OF THIS BILL
WOULD BACK FEEL THAT -- WE ALSO --
WORKED WITH THE GVERNOR TRY.
TO FOCUS ABOUT PUTTING THIS IN
THE BUDGET BUT WE'RE RUNNING
THIS THESE BILLS THROUGH TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- WE ACTUALLY GET
THAT -- BACK BILL FOR TO USE I
READ WOULD -- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHASING INS
OFFICE REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
READING WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOON TO BE
SENATOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE WE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- WE ARE
TOLD THEY ARE ANTICIPATING THIS
COSTS AND AND THIS BILL DOES THE
OLD TRUST BUT VERIFY AND AND WE
WANT ONCE AGAIN REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
SHERMAN MEMBERS POLY OR WE HAVE
SISKIYOU CHESS SHASTA COUNTIES
THEIR BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
ELECT THESE FIRES REALLY DO.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THE
SMALLEST COUNTIES -- SO -- DR --
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
EXCUSE ME WHILE WE DO SOME
COMMITTEE BUSINESS HERE CAN WE
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
DODD.
DODD HERE WILK [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCH LETTER HERE PORGES FORGES
HERE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHANGE HERE CHIANG
HERE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI HERE GLAZER
[inaudible]
HELLO.
WESTERN.
JONES.
JONES HERE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HERE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO HERE RUBIO WIENER.
HEY WE ALL CORN SO WE CAN
PROCEED SENATOR [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT.
WE HAVE WITNESSES WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
YOUR SINGLE FIFTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CHRIS ROCK KALEY
ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
STACEY HEAT RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD STACY.
ROBERTS BEAGLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY IN THE WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR CHUCK CLOSE AS FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU OKAY CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM TWO A. B. TWO FOUR
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD
ALRIGHT DODD AYE DODD AYE FIRST
[inaudible]
ONE WILK [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE BARGES.
OR JUST AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I
CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WEST SO.
JONES I'VE JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK AYE [inaudible]
WILK I THAT CAN HOLD TO OPEN --
UNCLE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA DO THE QUICK
QUICKLY THE CONSENT TO COME ON
OUT.
SOME A MEMBER TING.
WE DO THE KILL DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT ITEMS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND WAS AT
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU.
IF ANYTHING DOES ANYBODY WANT TO
TAKE ANYTHING OFF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS.
SEEING NONE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
SHOT.
HI DODD AYE WILK.
HI WILK AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE FORGES.
FORGES AYE BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD I CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WESTERN.
JONES FIVE JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER. ELEVEN ZERO SAN CALL
LEVEL ZERO THAT BILLS ON CALL --
WE'RE GONNA GO NOW T AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN SO REMEMBER TING
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN THE DISTRICT
BILL THE REVISED IS AN EXISTING
PROGRAM.
IN SAN FRANCISCO CREATING A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF FLEXIBILITY FOR
BUSINESS OWNERS THAT HAVE EIGHT
TYPE EIGHTY SEVEN LIQUOR LICENSE.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE
LICENSE HOLDER TO MOVE WITHIN A
NEIGHBORHOOD COURT OR?
THAT ARE SPECIFIED WITHIN
EXISTING LAW IT CREATES A A
LITTLE BIT OF FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT BUSINESS OWNERS ARE JUST
TIED TO THAT.
ONE SPOT IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND
GET THEM TO KEEP THE INTEGRITY
OF THE LIQUOR LICENSE BECAUSE IT
DOES ALLOW THEM TO MOVE WHEREVER
THEY WANTED ONLY.
A VERY LIMITED AMOUNT OF SPACE
THEY COULD MOVE INTO.
SO WITH THAT RESPECT AS RIVAL
FOR OUR DISTRICT BILL IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
OKAY GREAT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MOTION.
CENTER NIELSEN MOVES.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN
ELEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
I DODD AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ALLEN ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D FORGES.
FORGES AYE BRADFORD.
CHANG.
CHANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
HILL [inaudible]
WEST SO.
JONES I'VE JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO WIENER. TEN
ZERO TEN ZERO RULES ON CALL.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE. ELEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
THE NEXT -- AUTHOR WHAT WE GO
BACK AND VOTE ON ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB.
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WE HAVE A
MOTION [inaudible]
SO MOVE [inaudible]
MOVES.
CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE FOUR MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
HI DODD HI WILK WILK AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE BARGES BARGES AYE
BRADFORD.
CHANG CHANG AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL.
WHAT'S SO.
JONES.
JONES BY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
TINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER.
WIENER HI. ELEVEN ZERO ON CALL.
THAT TO HAS ELEVEN VOTES THAT
BILLS ON CALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS --
AB FOUR SIX NINE WELCOME
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
YOU CAN THE PRESENT FROM RIGHT
THERE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB FOR SIXTY NINE
WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT STATE RECORDS ARE
MANAGE PROPERLY AND CONSISTENTLY
SO THAT THE PUBLIC AND
RESEARCHERS CAN ACCESS THEM IN
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S.
STATE ARCHIVES.
AB FOR SIXTY NINE REQUIRES EACH
STATE AGENCY TO APPOINT A
RECORDS MANAGEMENT COORDINATOR
AND ALL SET AND NATIONAL AN
ONGOING RECORDS MANAGEMENT
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
NEWLY APPOINTED COORDINATORS.
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY NINE PROVIDES
NECESSARY IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
STATE INFORMATION GOVERNANCE BY
ENSURING MORE CONSISTENT
IMPLEMENTATION ACROSS STATE
DEPARTMENTS IN THE ARCHIVING
PROCESS. FIVE PLEASE TODAY TO
WELCOME AND A WITNESS IN SUPPORT
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER -- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SUCH ANIMAL HOUSE --
ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY OF STATE
ALEX PADILLA US SECRETARY PRETTY
IS THE SPONSOR OF AB.
FOUR SIX NINE WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS FOR TAKING
A LEAD ON THIS ISSUE ANDERSON OR
APPRECIATION FOR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF VERY THOUGHTFUL AND VERY
COMPLETE ANALYSIS -- AB A FOUR
SIX NINE AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
INDICATED AND SURE THAT STATE
RECORDS WILL BE CAREFULLY STORED
AND RECORDED BY RECORDS
MANAGEMENT COORDINATORS OF ALL
STATE ENTITIES -- THE SECRETARY
STATE OUT ALEX PADILLA I ASK
YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE TURN TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE THE BILL THE MOTION
BY CENTER WELCOME WE PLEASE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER
THANK YOU SO MUCH NUMBER.
FILE ITEM FOR EIGHTY FOUR SIX
NINE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
I THOUGHT I WILK HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D FORGES.
FORGES AYE BRADFORD.
CHANG.
CHANG AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE. TEN ZERO ON CALL.
THE BILL AS TEN VOTES TO ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TAKE CARE.
THIS IS HERE [inaudible]
NOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AB FOR
TWENTY NINE FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
THREE MOTOR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS [inaudible]
PLUS YOU.
AB FOR TWENTY NINE WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION TO CREATE AN
INVENTORY OF POTENTIALLY
SEISMICALLY VULNERABLE BUILDINGS
LOCATED IN THE TWENTY NINE
COUNTIES.
OF MOST SEISMIC RISK CALIFORNIA
HAS THOUSANDS OF BUILDINGS THAT
ARE KNOWN TO PRESENT A
HEIGHTENED EARTHQUAKE RISK OF
DEATH INJURY AND DAMAGE.
BASED ON THEIR AGE STRUCTURAL
SYSTEMS SIZE AND LOCATION.
THE CHRONIC LABOR AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SHORTAGES MOST
CALIFORNIA CITIES ALREADY SUFFER
WOULD DRAMATICALLY INCREASE FOR
YEARS TO COME FOLLOWING A LARGE
EARTHQUAKE.
THE MOST RECENT CALIFORNIA
SHAKEOUT STUDY ESTIMATES THAT A
MAJOR QUAKE ALONG THE SAN
ANDREAS FAULT.
COULD CAUSE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
PHYSICAL AND ECONOMIC DAMAGE.
AND EIGHTEEN HUNDRED OR MORE
DEATHS.
IN MAY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ARIZONA RAND DISASTER DRILLS IN
ANTICIPATION OF RECEIVING.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIANS.
THE THE STATED IT AS REFUGEES
FOLLOWING SIGNIFICANT SEISMIC
ACTIVITY ON THE SAN ANDREAS
FAULT.
WHILE SOME CITIES MOST NOTABLY
LOS ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO
HAVE IDENTIFIED VULNERABLE
BUILDINGS AND IMPLEMENTED
MANDATORY RETROFITS.
LARGE PARTS OF THIS THE HAVE
NOTS.
BEFORE WE CAN SUPPORT LOCAL
MITIGATION EFFORTS THROUGH GRANT
PROGRAMS WE MUST GAIN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE EXTENT.
OF OUR VULNERABILITIES AND
ACCURATE IN THE INVENTORY.
IS AN ESSENTIAL FIRST STEP IN
DEVELOPING LONGER TERM TARGETED
SOLUTIONS IN ADVANCE OF MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE I WILL CONTINUE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION TO ENSURE A
BEAT.
FOR TWENTY NINE IS A COST
EFFECTIVE SURVEY OF SEISMICALLY
VULNERABLE BUILDINGS AND
CALIFORNIA'S MOST EARTHQUAKE
PRONE AREAS -- I'M JOINED TODAY
BY STARS SAY IT -- WITH THE
PUBLIC POLICY CHAIR OF FOR THE
EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING RESEARCH
INSTITUTE.
AS WELL AS KATIE ALMONT WITH --
CALVO.
ON BEHALF OF KALPOE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WHAT IS TO SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS OUR ESSAY ED AND I AM
THE PUBLIC POLICY CHAIR FOR THE
EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING RESEARCH
INSTITUTE OR E. R. I..
WE ARE A NATIONAL TECHNICAL
SOCIETY OF EXPERTS INCLUDING
ENGINEERS ARCHITECTS.
PUBLIC POLICY AND SOCIAL SCIENCE
EXPERTS DEDICATED TO REDUCING
EARTHQUAKE RISK BASED IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR TWO NINE WHICH CALLS FOR A
STATE WIDE INVENTORY OF
BUILDINGS.
KNOWN TO BE SUBJECT TO DAMAGE OR
COLLAPSE AND EARTHQUAKES.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP AND TOWARD
QUANTIFYING THE EXTENT AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THE PROBLEM
ACROSS THE STATE OF VULNERABLE
BUILDINGS.
HERE I BELIEVES IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT THIS IS JUST A FIRST STEP
TOWARD FUTURE LEGISLATION THAT
FOCUSES PRIORITIES AND SUPPORTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN IDENTIFYING
AND RETROFITTING THESE BUILDINGS.
SOME OF WHICH ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS CRITICAL WORK.
WE ARE ALSO VERY PLEASE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION SETS BUT THE
SEVEN FIFTY COMMISSION AND WE
HAVE CONFIDENCE.
IN THEIR EXPERTISE IS THE TO
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE SUCH AN
INVENTORY. TO BE CONDUCTED AT
THE CITY LEVEL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR CARRYING A MEDICATION
PROGRAMS IN THE FUTURE RESTS AND
TO IDENTIFY THE USE OF
STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES OF THESE
BUILDINGS.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST
LIKELY ACTIVE REGION IN THE KIND
COUNTRY OUTSIDE OF ALASKAN.
WITH A 99% CHANCE OF ONE OR MORE
MAGNITUDE SIX POINT SEVEN OR
GREATER EARTHQUAKES BEFORE.
TWENTY FORTY TWO WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS AN IMPERATIVE BUILDS IS
TAKE A FIRST STEP TOWARD --
REDUCING THE RISK OF OUR
BUILDINGS AND WE ARE VERY.
THANKFUL FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NAZARIAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
SEISMIC SAFETY AND CHAMPIONING
THIS BILL IN OTHER BILLS.
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ITS WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS MEAN
ISCHEMIC KATIE ALMOND AND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS AND I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO ECHO OUR COALITION PARTNERS
THOUGHTS ON THIS BILL AND THAT
IT IS A CRUCIAL FIRST STEP IN
LOOKING AT SEISMIC SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH CALVO AND THE
COALITION PARTNERS TO INTEGRATE
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT APPROACH
FOR THIS PROGRAM COUPLE DID
OPPOSE THE SIMILAR BILL THAT AND
IS THERE IN PROPOSAL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN PROPOSED LAST
YEAR.
AS IT WAS A STATEWIDE MANDATE
AND AT IDENTIFIED LOCAL FUNDS AS
A POSSIBLE SOURCE FOR THE
PROGRAM HOWEVER NOW WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR IN HIS OFFICE WE WERE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH THAT.
AB FOR TWENTY NINE THIS YEAR'S
BILL WILL FOCUS ON THE MOST
TWENTY NINE VULNERABLE COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA IDENTIFIES FEDERAL
GRANTS AND THE GENERAL FUND AS
POSSIBLE SOURCES FOR FUNDING FOR
THE PROGRAM.
AND IT DIRECTS THE EISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION TO HIRE A
THIRD PARTY TO CONDUCT THE
INVENTORY -- WITH THESE THOUGHTS
COUPLE LET'S IT SUPPORTS AND
AGAIN THANKS THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US.
I'M JUST THINKING IF CAO BOW IS
EVEN FORGOT IT'S BEEN HERE FIVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS BUT WHAT IS IT YES SO
WE ARE THE BUILDING OFFICIALS
FOR ALL THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COUNTIES AND CITIES WE REPRESENT
ABOUT 95%.
OF THE COUNTIES AND CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE --
BASICALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT.
PERFECT THIS WITNESS THANK YOU
BURKE [inaudible]
CLOSE.
OR IF YOUR AWARENESS IN
OPPOSITION OKAY AB.
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID
JOHNSON ABOUT THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA IN SUPPORT.
THE KIDDOS HERE ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN YOU COULD YOU REPEAT THAT THE
MIKE DIDN'T GET ON THE PERSONAL
KIDDOS HERE ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
AND CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IS
DAVID BONTA WITH SOME STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER IN SAN FRANCISCO I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE E. R. I AND
ACTIVE IN THIS FOR TWENTY YEARS
SO SEASON.
OF CALIFORNIA A SPEAKING ONLY
FOR MYSELF TODAY WITH MY CLIENTS
INCLUDE FEMA THE CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY A BAD HIT
THE CITIES OF SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND BERKELEY HAYWARD.
MOUNTAIN VIEW THEY SEEK MY
ADVICE ON EXACTLY THIS TOPIC
EXISTING BUILDINGS IN EARTHQUAKE
RISK REDUCTION POP POLICY ALL OF
THIS IS SCARY STATISTICS YOU
HEARD FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS
IN THIS AREA.
ARE LEGIT.
THE PROBLEM IS THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
IS THE FIRST STEP IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION I'M GONNA REGION TAKE
NOTES LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BILL.
IF YOU THINK THIS BILL WILL
STATEWIDE
BUILDINGS IT WON'T BECAUSE THERE
IS NO SUCH PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA JUST MORE SEISMIC
RETROFIT BEING DONE.
ACROSS THE STATE THAN EVER
BEFORE AND NONE OF IT REQUIRED
WHAT THIS BILL IS OFFERING TO
PRODUCE THE FUNDAMENTAL
ASSUMPTION OF THIS BILL THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE DATA WERE THAT WE
NEED SACRAMENTO TO PROVIDE IT.
IS SIMPLY WRONG IF YOU THINK
THIS BILL WILL PRODUCE USEFUL
DATA IT WILL NOT USEFUL DATE IS
NOT JUST ACCOUNT OF BUILDINGS
WITH NO CONTEXT WE KNOW THIS
FROM PAST STATEWIDE EFFORTS AND
FROM MY WORK WITH VARIOUS
JURISDICTIONS.
SEAT WIDE INVENTORIES DO NOT
PRODUCE INFORMATION THAT IS
USEFUL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHATEVER IS PRODUCED BY THIS
BILL WILL HAVE TO BE RE DONE BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BEFORE THEY
CAN EVEN USE IT.
IF YOU THINK THIS BILL WILL
ACTIVATE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO
THAT WORK IT WILL NOT MORE TO
IMPLEMENT RECORD FOR PROGRAMS IT
WILL NOT ON THE COUNTRY THIS
BILL GIVES MOST JURISDICTIONS
PERMISSION TO DO NOTHING FOR
THREE YEARS.
IN FACT WE KNOW THE CAL BONES IN
THEIR STATEMENT HAS SAID THE
REASON THEY SUPPORT THE BILL IS
BECAUSE IT'S NO LONGER UNFUNDED
MANDATE WHICH MEANS THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING BECAUSE THEY
THINK THE STATE.
IS GOING TO DO THEIR WORK FOR
THEM THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THAT
COULD ACTUALLY STOP.
MORE RISK REDUCTION THEN IT
STARTS IF YOU THINK THE BILL
WILL BE MORE FEASIBLE OR COST
EFFECTIVE BECAUSE THE WORK IS
BEING DONE BY THE STATE INSTEAD
OF BY THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
IT WON'T.
ANY EMPHASIS ON UNIFORMITY HERE
IS ENTIRELY MISPLACED AS WE CAN
PROVE BY LOOKING AT ALL THE SOFT
STORY PROGRAMS AND RIGHT NOW IN
EFFECT AROUND THE STATE.
ALL OF THEM ARE DIFFERENT ALL
THE MAKE A DIFFERENT DEFINITION
OF THE BUILDING ALL OF THEM ARE
ON EFFECTIVE HOWEVER BECAUSE
THEY ARE CUSTOMIZED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
INVENTORY IS MOST EFFECTIVE WHEN
THE WORKS WITH LOCAL RECORDS AND
LOCAL EXPERTISE WHICH THIS BILL
EXPLICITLY RULES OUT.
FINALLY IN SUMMARY IF YOU THINK
THIS BILL IS A GOOD WAY TO SPEND
A FEW MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
YOU INTERESTED IN EARTHQUAKE
SAFETY WORST CHRISTMAS
PRODUCTION I HOPE I'VE SHOWN YOU
WHY IT'S NOT GOOD INTENTIONS
ALONE DO NOT MAKE.
GOOD POLICY AGAIN FIRST STEP
KALRA FIRST STEP IF YOU WANT
IT'S A FIRST STEP IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION NOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS THE STATE CAN DO. TO HELP
INVENTORY EFFORTS AND TO HELP
LOWER LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BUT
THEY ALL START WITH RECOGNIZING
THIS KEY TRUTH.
WITH QUICK MITIGATION IN
CALIFORNIA IS CONCEIVED PLAN.
LEGISLATORS FUNDED AND
IMPLEMENTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SO ANYTHING THAT'S PRODUCED FROM
THIS BILL WILL HAVE TO BE RE
DONE NO MATTER IF YOU GIVE IT TO
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MOST
DON'T WANT IT THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO TAKE IT.
I CAN COME BACK AND TALK ABOUT
THE SUPPORTERS IN THE OTHER
IDEAS IF YOU WANT TO SUMMARIZE
PLEASE YOU CAN BE. FOR SEISMIC
SAFETY.
AND SO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
YOU CAN BE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF EFFECTIVE EARTHQUAKE RISK
REDUCTION PLANNING AND STILL
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
RIGHT YOU CAN BE OUT TWO MINUTES.
IT WAY MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
THEIR SUMMERS THAT QUICKLY OKAY
I'LL JUST ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
THE LEGISLATURE FINALLY SHOWN
SOME WILLINGNESS TO SPEND SOME
MONEY ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE.
LET'S NOT WASTE IT TAKEN THREE
YEARS TO PRODUCE SOMETHING THAT
NOT A SINGLE JURISDICTION WE USE
I ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE COMING TO
THE MICROPHONE SO -- CENTER
BORDERS.
COME BACK TOWARD THANK YOU --
THIS SHERMAN.
OR MAKE YOUR NINE OR STAND YOU
TO YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS IS
THAT YOU DON'T FIND IT USEFUL
BUT CUMBERSOME.
AND IT GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION I'M NOT CERTAIN I
UNDERSTAND PLACE MAKING TWO
MISTAKES IS FOCUSING THE EFFORT
AT THE STATE LEVEL WHEN ALL THE
REAL WORK IS GOING TO BE DONE
AND ALL THE USE OF THE DATA IS
PRODUCED BY THIS WILL HAVE TO BE
DONE AT THE LOCAL.
LEVEL AND A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
COST WE'RE SPENDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
GONNA BE USED WHEN WE COULD.
REALLY MAKE THE BILL MUCH BETTER.
AND SPENT IN A MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY AND THE LOCALS
COULD NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
INFORMATION.
IT WILL NOT BE USEFUL TO THEM
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THEY NEED WHEN THEY
PRODUCE THEIR OWN LOCAL
MEDICATION PROGRAMS AND IT'S NOT
WITH THIS BILL COULD POSSIBLY
PRODUCE.
BASED ON THE DATA THEY HAVE WE
HAVE -- ANY COUNTERPOINTS TO
THAT -- I AM HAPPY.
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF RESPONSE BUT
THEN HAVE THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER I GIVE A MUCH MORE IN
DEPTH RESPONSE -- FIRST JUST
JUST. TO SUMMARIZE IF YOU CAN.
WILL THE LOCALS FIND THIS A
BENEFIT WILL THIS THE FOLKS AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND ON WITHIN
THE TWENTY NINE COUNTIES FIND
THIS OF BENEFITS.
YES.
THIS WAS KIND OF A COST CUTTING
MEASURE.
LAST YEAR'S BILL THAT THE
GOVERNOR VETOED WAS GONNA BE IT
WAS MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND IT REQUIRED MORE FUNDING --
AND IT PUT SOME OF THAT BURDEN
ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THIS WAS A WAY OF REDUCING IT TO
ONLY THE TWENTY NINE MOST
SEISMICALLY ACTIVE.
COUNTIES -- THAT WILL BENEFIT
FROM HAVING THIS MEASURE IN
PLACE AND HAVE AND FOR US TO
HAVE IN AN ACCURATE COUNT.
OF WHAT THE MOST VULNERABLE.
AS FAR IN CALIFORNIA THAT WILL
NEW ADDRESSING LANDED MANDATE
FROM AN EARLIER VERSION SCALED
BACK.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THERE ARE TWO LETTER THANK YOU
FOR SHARE I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE INFORMATION IS POWER.
IN IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
THAT I REPRESENT.
IN THE THREE TO WE'VE HAD THE
ESPECIALLY IN WITH YOUR WHICH IS.
IN MY DISTRICT -- HAVE BEEN
INFORMATION WOULD HAV PREPARED
US IN I THINK THIS IS WILL OPEN
THAT DOOR I SEE THAT.
BUT AND I HOPE IT LEAVES THE
DOOR TO RETROFITTING OF SOME OF
THESE BUILDINGS BECAUSE YOU KNOW --
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE FOUR THREE
TWO THESE ARE THE OLDER
BUILDINGS SO -- DO YOU SEE A
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE COUNTIES AND CITY
MANAGERS AND SO ON TO GRAB THE
INFORMATION WORK TOGETHER ON IT
WOULD YOU ENVISION FROM THIS.
IT'S LIKE GOING TO A DOCTOR YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE UNTIL
THE DIET DOCTOR DIAGNOSES WHAT
YOU HAVE EXACTLY.
AND THEN LAYS OUT FOR YOU WHAT
THE TREATMENT IS GOING TO BE
THIS IS THE SAME THING.
IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT BUILDINGS
ARE VULNERABLE HOW ARE WE GONNA
HAVE AN ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO RETROFIT OR FIX.
AND HOW MUCH OF A COST IT'S
GOING TO IMPOSE AND AT THAT
POINT FIGURE OUT WITH THE STATE
OR GOVERNMENT'S PORTION OF
CONTRIBUTION TO HELP LOCAL
BUSINESSES OUT WOULD BE.
SO INSTEAD OF JUST INTRODUCING
BUT I'VE ALSO HAD LEGISLATION ON
TAX CREDITS -- SO THAT IT WOULD
WE WOULD HAVE SOMETHING IN PLACE
TO FUND THE NEEDS THAT ARE GONNA
COME FROM THIS INVENTORY LIST.
SO IT'S A IT'S BEEN A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH OVER THE YEARS --
BUT WE'VE BEEN REFINING IT OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST FOUR FIVE
YEARS ALSO TO GET IT TO THE
PLACE WHERE WE HAVE THE DATA
THAT WE NEED WE'RE ALSO WORKING
ON STRENGTHENING BUILDING CODES
AND THEN WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR TAX CREDITS. TO
ALLOW -- FOR THESE TYPES OF
FIXES THAT ARE NECESSARY.
LET'S HOPE THIS WILL TAKE YOU
OVER THE TOP AND GET THE
GOVERNOR SIGNATURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- WILK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
QUESTION OF THE OPPOSITION IN A
COMMENT.
I JUST SO I WANT TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T WANT TO NAME
DROPPING THE YEAR HERE'S AN
INDIVIDUAL SO YOU DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
YOU WORK WITH HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THREE JURISDICTIONS HAVE ALREADY
CALLED ME AND ASKED.
ME IF THEY SHOULD STOP THEIR
ONGOING PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL THAT THAT'S THAT'S THE WAY
THEY SEE IT NO I'M NOT SPEAKING
ON THEIR BEHALF GOOD I WANTED.
I WANT TO JUST MAKE THAT
PERFECTLY CLEAR.
SO YOU AND I BOTH INDOOR AND
THEN THE NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE.
AND I WORKED I WAS CHIEF OF
STAFF AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
TIME AND THAT.
THE FAMOUS APARTMENT BUILDING IN
NORTH IN NORTHRIDGE PANCAKED AND
PEOPLE DIED SO I WAS IT IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR BROADER BILL I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I KNOW THIS IS GREATLY NEEDED
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING SO GOD GET ON THIS ON THIS
ISSUE.
AND I CAN SUPPORT TODAY AND GET
ON THE FLOOR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FILE.
I THINK YOU MAKE SOME VERY
COMPELLING -- YOUR COMMENTS IN
IT IN POINTS IN YOUR IN YOUR
TESTIMONY.
THE FACT IN IN I DON'T WANT YOU
TO RESPOND OKAY APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS AND NONE
OF THE COMMUNITIES IF YOU HAD
SAN FRANCISCO IN HERE IN THE
COMMUNITIES.
IN WHICH YOU SERVED THOUGHT
ENOUGH ABOUT THIS BILL WAS COULD
BE SO NEGATIVE THEIR COMMUNITIES --
THEY SHOULD ORDER -- DO OR WOULD
BE HERE IT WILL -- WELCOME.
MAYBE THEY CAN BE THERE FOR
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER PORTANTINO
WILL.
WORK ON THAT -- BUT NEVER THAT
BUT NEVER THE LESS THE WAY I SEE
IT IS SOMEBODY THAT JUST WENT
THROUGH A WILDFIRE.
ANY OTHER STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
WE VOTED ON A BILL YESTERDAY OR
SOCK IN A IN IN A COMMITTEE
ANOTHER BILL WERE -- TO TO BE
SENATOR DOLLY HE WAS JUST HERE
WHAT'S MONEY FOR HIS COMMUNITY
AFTER A NATURAL DISASTER LET ME
TELL YOU.
WHEN THESE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE MAJOR MAJOR DAMAGE TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE THEY COMING
BACK TO THE BACK BILL ON THEIR
TAXES AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO I
REALLY BELIEVE?
THAT HAVING SOME MANAGEMENT
ADULT SUPERVISION IN SACRAMENTO
THAT KIND OF THE TERM KNOWS AND
UNDERSTANDS WHERE THESE
BUILDINGS ARE ILL THE WILL HELP
MAYBE TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL
PLANNING -- IN THE FUTURE SO THE
CHAIR RECOMMENDS AN AYE VOTE CAN
I HAVE A MOTION MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR A AND
CENTER BOARD JUST WE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTY FOUR
TWO NINE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD BY
GOD I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI. FOR JUST.
FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD.
CHANG CHANG AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WHY SO [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN THANKS NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE. TEN ZERO ON TEN IS
THERE THE BILL'S ON CALL THANKS
TO ALL THE WITNESSES THANK YOU
SO MUCH THAT MAKE YOUR SO
REMEMBER CERVANTES.
BOATS THAT WAS CENTER DALY HERE
FOR YES HE WAS.
IN HIS NUMBER ONE ON THE CHART.
SO COME ON UP CENTER DALY.
MY APOLOGIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES.
EITHER ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS A BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION IT'S SIMPLY UPDATES.
OUR LAW TO REFLECT CHANGES IN
FEDERAL LAW -- THE GOAL IS TO
ALLOW NATURAL ADDITIVES.
IN THE BEER MAKING PROCESS --
IT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF EXCITING
TO SUGGEST A REDEFINITION OF
BEER -- AND I THINK IT'S IT'S
ACTUALLY RELATIVELY SIMPLE BILL
IT SIMPLY KEEPS CALIFORNIA LAW
CURRENT WITH THE TIMES WE ARE IN --
CRAFT BEER MAKERS ARE.
NOW AND HAVE BEEN RECENTLY IN
RECENT YEARS ADDING NATURAL
ADDITIVES TO PEER -- BOB --
CHRIS WALKERS HERE WITH THE
CRAFT [inaudible]
BREWERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS WALKER BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION -- THIS BILL SIMPLY --
CONFORMS CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
WHEN IT COMES THE DEFINITION OF
BEER WITH THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
ALLOWING BEER AND HONEY ANOTHER
ADJUNCT TO BE ADDED DURING
FERMENTATION -- THIS IS A
PRACTICE THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF YEARS --
AND WERE SIMPLY UPDATING STATE
LAW TO CONFORM WITH FEDERAL AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
BACK TO YOU -- THE COMMITTEE
CENTER WILK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO THIS
BILL IS NOT A CAPITULATION TO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AS IT
COULD YOU MENTION IS IN
CONFORMANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW.
I WOULDN'T CARE IT IF IF IT WERE
A CHARACTERIZED IN THAT MANNER
ALL RIGHT WELL 'M.
PREPARED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF TO TWEAK
THE BILL A LITTLE BIT TO
ACCOMMODATE -- THE WINE INDUSTRY.
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
NO -- OVERLAPPING IN IN ANYWAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THAT
YEAH THE OTHER CUT THE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS STILL GET A
MOTION BY SENATOR WELCOME TO
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE WOULD YOU
LIKE.
TO CLOSE AYE BY APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR QUESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEES
WORK AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU HE SELLER
AND FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO OH FIVE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
DODD.
DODD AYE WILK I WILK I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE BARGES.
BARGES AYE BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WESTERN [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
AT NINE ZERO ON CALL BILL HAS
DIED VOTES TALK CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO ALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SURVIVE DAIS
WELCOME.
AB FOR SEVEN SEVEN WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING HERE GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB FOR SEVEN SEVEN TODAY.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE
INCONSISTENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
REGARDING EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PLANNING FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY DURING A DISASTER IT
IS VITAL TO UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
AFTER THE FIRE DISASTERS OF THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN WORKING TO
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
THE COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
WILDFIRES HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY SENIORS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
AB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN SIX TO
ENSURE THAT WE RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY DURING A DISASTER BY
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS AD
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE NOT
TRADITIONALLY INVOLVED IN
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS.
WE MUST STRIVE TO DEVELOP
EMERGENCY PLANS IN COLLABORATION
WITH OUR ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS POPULATION ADVOCATES AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS.
AS A LEGISLATURE WE MUST ENSURE
THAT WE ARE PRO ACTIVELY WORKING
TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
INFORMATION NEEDED SERVICES AND
RISK COMMUNICATION FOR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WITH AB
FOR SEVEN SEVEN WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION.
AND XP EXECUTION OF EMERGENCY
PLANNING WORKS FOR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
BY INSURANCE STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS THAT WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS POPULATION
BEFORE TRAGEDY OCCURS.
A SENATORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS BUT I DO
HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS WITH ME TO
TESTIFIED THAT IS COUNCIL MEMBER
NET.
AND MICHAEL AND NO T. FROM THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS CHARLES DYNAMICS OF
ADVOCATE.
AND A VICE CHAIR OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON THE BILL IS STILL IS.
A REPRESENT THE NORTH STATE
REGION.
ON THE STATE COUNCIL I'M ALSO
JOINED SUPPORTED BY J. BY
MICHAEL'S MCNULTY.
BERMAN STAFF FROM THE TO THE
CITY COUNCIL I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN WHICH REQUIRE COUNTY OR
CITY OR COUNTY. TO INCLUDE.
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE ACCESS
AND FUNCTION NEEDS POPULATION.
WHICH INCLUDES PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPERS
BUILDINGS AND EMERGENCY PLANNING.
I LOST MY HOME.
IN PARIS DURING A CAMPFIRE.
I BELIEVE GREATER PLANNING
EFFORTS.
COULD HAVE HELPED FILL IN THE
GAPS I ENCOUNTERED DURING THE
MERCY.
ACTUATION.
DURING A CAMPFIRE I KNEW THERE
WAS A WARNING STATUS IN MY
REGION.
MY SONG BUT I DID NOT KNOW THE
TRUE NATURE OF THE SITUATION
TOLD THE REGIONAL CENTER CALLED
ME.
ONCE I RECEIVE THE CALL FOR
MERRY SO I HAD TO MAKE A
DECISION A GRAB.
MY SON MY MY MY MY ANIMALS AN
ANALYSIS TO BACK THROUGH MY OWN.
WAS AND GATHER MY THINGS IT TOOK
ME THREE HOURS TO GET FROM --
PARADISE DID SHE COPE WITH WHICH
ARE USUALLY TAKES LIKE FIFTEEN
MINUTES. TO ME MY WIFE I DID NOT
KNOW WHERE WHERE WE WILL BE ABLE
TO FIND SHELTER IT WAS ALL ONLY
THROUGH MY SENDS AN ORDER
FRIENDS.
WE WERE ABLE TO FIND SHELTER AT
CHURCHILL OUT ANIMALS.
WE WERE LUCKY TO ESCAPE AND TO
FIND.
ENSURING THE VOICES OF THE AXIS
OF FUNCTION NEEDS COMMUNITY AS
PART OF PLANNING PROCESS ACROSS
THE STATE.
ENTER THE GREATER LEVEL OF
SAFETY FOR ALL OF US.
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM THANKFUL FOR THE WORK.
I WAS A MEMBER WITH CERVANTES.
AND PLEASE SUPPORT THIS AN
IMPORTANT BILL.
AT THE REPRESENT OF THE STATE
COUNCIL THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MY COUNTY CITY COUNCIL
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT VICE CHAIR
NOT AND HAPPY TO BE HERE TO IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
INDIA BUT ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFIED SUPPORT ANY BUT I
CANCER I CAN'T SEE BEYOND.
SEVEN HELLO THERE LOWERING GOOD
MORNING -- MY NAME'S -- CARE
SOME REPRESENTING -- DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WHERE SUPPORT.
PASSAGE THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT [inaudible]
WITNESS.
HELLO UNDERGONE DRESS ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
SOCIAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION CAN'T
IMAGINE.
SO WILL TURN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
IN THE BY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS -- I THINK IT'S
AN AMAZING BILL I THINK SO OFTEN
THIS POPULATIONS -- DO GET
OVERLOOKED -- I AM REALLY
PLEASED TO REPORT THOUGH THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALREADY HAS THIS IS ONGOING JUST
AS EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS PLANNING --
YEAH MAKES IT WORK BETTER FOR
THE SNOW BUT DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER THAT WAS IN -- THE SNOW
VALLEY HAD TO RELOCATE TWICE
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS --
IN OUR SOCIETY GOT MOVE FIRST TO
THE CINEMA -- VETERAN SERRANO
CENTER YOU'RE YOU'RE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
AND THEN WITH THE FIRE STARTED
APPROACHING THEM TO THEY'VE
MOVED ALL THE WAY OVER TO DIXON.
IT JUST DID IT ABSOLUTELY
AMAZING JOB SO THERE ARE
EXAMPLES.
THIS PLANNING CAN MAKE T HAPPEN
AND AND AND DO IT VERY VERY WELL
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IN THE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LIVING -- CENTRALLY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERYTHING THAT THEY
ARE INCLUDED IN THESE PLANTS SO
THEY GET THE SAME TYPE OF
SERVICE SO THANK YOU -- FOR
BRING THIS BILL TO US TODAY ANY --
CLOSING REMARKS.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND TAKE YOU TO
THE SENATORS SIDE TEACHER VIEW
FOR YOUR FOCUS ON THIS ATTENTION
AND TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY ON THIS BILL.
A THIRD -- CHANG -- MOVED TO
BILL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
CORPORATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
BY DODD AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE BURGESS -- FORGES
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE CHANGE I
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WHAT'S SO.
JONES RIGHT JONES I NIELSEN
HIGHER NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE. TWELVE ZERO HOLDEN
OPENS TWELVE VOTES WILL HOLD THE
RUN.
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES FOR
COMING TODAY.
APPRECIATE IT.
CENTER -- SKEWS ME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AB [inaudible] SIX
FIVE THREE SEVEN TO THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB SIX
FIFTY THREE WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE DIRECTOR OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO ENTER INTO A
LEASE AGREEMENT WITH THE COUNTY
OF LA. FOR PORTION OF THE WEST
LOS ANGELES NATIONAL GUARD
ARMORY SITE OVER THE LAST TO
APPROXIMATE YEAR AND A HALF THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
SUPERVISOR SHE WILL KILL HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AS
WELL AS RELEVANT CITY STATE.
AND FEDERAL PARTNERS TO DISCUSS
THE FEASIBILITY OF BUILDING A
YEAR ROUND BRIDGE HOUSING SITE
AT THE PROPERTY.
THE WEST LA ARMORY IS SITUATED
WITHIN SERVICE PLANNING AREA OR
WHAT WE CALL SPA FIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHICH COVERS MOST
OF THE WEST SIDE AND SPANS SOME
OF THE HIGHEST PROPERTY VALUES.
IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
SAY INTERIM HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO THE
OUTRAGEOUS COST OF LAND IN OUR
ALREADY DANCE REGION I DON'T
HAVE TO TELL YOU.
ABOUT THE CRISIS AND
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IT'S BEEN ALL OVER
THE NEWSPAPER FOR THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS -- AND BEYOND.
ODJICK WOULD BE THE FIRST BRIDGE
HOUSING SECTOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL.
INDIVIDUALS AND SPOT FIVE IN
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS THE IT'S
ACTUALLY OVER TWENTY YEARS THE
SPECIFICS OF THE PROJECT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED WITH COUNTY
ARCHITECT.
AND THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
DESIGNS SHOULD BE COMPLETED OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
THE PROJECT WILL INCLUDE A
PARKING STRUCTURE -- WHERE
SURFACE PARKING CURRENTLY EXISTS
TO ASSIST THE NATIONAL GUARD IN
ALLEVIATING THEIR OWN PARKING
BURDEN AND ALL PARTIES AGREE
THAT THIS PROJECT WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT ENHANCEMENT TO THE
PROPERTY?
HERE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE --
STEPHANIE CONE WAS SUPERVISOR
SHE'LL KILLS OFFICE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
JUST LETTING YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
SUPPORT SUPPORT HERE SO THAT
MEANS KEEP IT SHORT.
YEAH.
I DOUBT THAT'S POSSIBLE SENATOR
BUT COLON I GUESS THERE'S NOT A
LOT FOR ME TO SAY THEN.
I DECIDED YOU COME ALL THE WAY
UP FROM LOS ANGELES TO PLEASE
IT'S OKAY I'LL JUST GIVE YOU MY
GENERAL SPIEL ABOUT.
HOMELESSNESS IN IN LA COUNTY I
AM SO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM FOR SUPPORTING LA COUNTY
AND SUPERVISOR KILL IN THIS
EFFORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
SERVICES AUTHORITY IS TO TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNT WHICH I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
HAVE SEEN.
IN THE NEWS OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS FOUND THAT THERE ARE TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
INDIVIDUALS AND SHELTERED IN A
SERVICE AREA.
FIVE AND ONLY FIFTEEN BEDS FOR
INDEPENDENT INDIVIDUALS WITH NO
SPECIALIZED CATEGORY SUCH AS
VETERANS TRANSITION AGE TO YOUTH
AND FAMILIES -- THIS IS A
STRIKINGLY KNOWN I'M LOW NUMBER
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS -- THE
AREAS THAT BORDER SERVICE AREA
FIVE SERVICE AREA FOR HAS OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED BAD SERVICE AREA
TO YOU IN THE VALLEY HAS ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED BEDS -- IN APRIL
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS MOVED TO EXAMINE
ALL OF OUR WINTER SHELTER MODELS
IN THE COUNTY -- TO DETERMINE IF
THEY COULD BETTER SERVE THE
GROWING HOMELESS POPULATION.
OUR EFFORTS ARE TO TURN THOSE
WITH WINTER SHELTERS INTO TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN YEAR ROUND BRIDGE
HOUSING FACILITIES WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE.
ALONGSIDE THIS BILL IS A FEDERAL
BILL INTRODUCED BY SENATOR
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND CONGRESSMAN
LOU AND CONGRESSWOMAN KATIE HILL
THAT'S ALSO MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS SO WE EXPECT THAT THIS
PROJECT WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE
ALONG WITH YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I SAW A KID US HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE OTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HE WILL TURN TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA -- ANY CLOSING REMARKS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU -- HI MISTER CHAIR
GIVEN THE A STATE OF THE CRISIS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MOVE THIS
PROJECT LONG AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE FILE ITEM SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY THREE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE.
DODD HI DODD AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ALLEN ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HIGH FORGES.
FORGES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGED.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WESSEL.
JOHNS.
JOHNS I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER RIGHT WIENER HI. TWELVE
ZERO ON CALL.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES ON
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SOME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE ITEM
NUMBER -- TEN A. B..
TEN THIRTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF LAST
YEAR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR CONDUCTED AN AUDIT OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
THAT REVEALED SOME VERY%
TROUBLING FINDINGS.
NAMELY THE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAD BEEN ISSUING
GRANTS WHERE THE GRANT EVALUATOR
HAD A DIRECT AND CONFLICTING
INTEREST WITH THE APPLICANT TO
THAT GRANT.
THE AUDITOR RECOMMENDED THAT WE
NOT ALLOW THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR
WITH STATE AGENCIES ISSUING
GRANTS IN THE FUTURE THIS BILL
AB TEN THIRTEEN IMPLEMENTS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE AUDITOR.
IT INSTITUTES A IVE YEAR
pMEMBERS WERE ORGANIZATION ALSO
SERVING ON THE EVALUATION
COMMITTEE THAT ESTIMATES THE
GRANT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR WORK AND YOUR
STAFF WORK ON THIS BILL -- WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT TO WHICH CLARIFIES
THAT FEDERAL AGENCIES ARE
INCLUDED IN THE DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT ARE EXEMPT
FROM THE REQUIREMENTS -- WHEN
THEY APPLY FOR A GRANT?
WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
ABOUT.
TEN THIRTEEN WE ARE MOST BY
SENATOR BRADFORD ANY WITNESSES
SUPPORT CAN WITNESSES OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE ANY COMMENTS FROM
ANY OF THE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE THAT MOTION WE CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY
TEN THIRTEEN MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
DODD HI DODD AYE WILK ALL RIGHT
WILL AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE BARGES FOR JUST
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE CHIANG AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WHAT'S SO [inaudible]
JOHN.
JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER WIENER AYE [inaudible]
THE FROM THE TO LEVIN ZERO ON
CALL FOR THE TO ABSENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THOSE ON CALL.
SO LET'S SERVE CALL THE ROLL
STARTING FROM THE TOP PLEASE
[inaudible] THIRTY CONSENT.
START WITH THE CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
GLAZER.
HELLO.
PLEASE.
GLAZER AYE.
THANK YOU HELL [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
RUBIO WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER I HOLDEN ON CRAWFORD ONE
MORMONS AND TWENTY THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTY FIVE ALL BILL STILL ON
CALL FILE ITEM TWO A. B. TWO
FOUR SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
GLAZER I PLEASE THEIR AYE HILL
[inaudible]
REALLY COOL [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SORRY PUESTO.
RUBIO WIENER.
HERE I TWELVE ZERO ON CALL FOR
THE ONLY NUMBER I'M SORRY MR
CHAIRED DID YOU GET ME A NUMBER --
ONE WE'VE DONE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND NOW WE'RE ON TO ITEM TWO OH
I'M SORRY OKAY SO -- I HAVE YOU
ON THIS YES. TWELVE ZERO ON
TWELVE FOR THE ON CALL.
FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTY FOUR TWO
NINE MOTIONS YOU PASS THROUGH
PERFORATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE TEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER HIGH HILL.
ABSENT OR WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES.
JONES I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI FILE ITEM FOR EIGHTY FOUR SIX
NINE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BOTH TEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
CHECK OUT WEST SO [inaudible]
JOHNSON.
JONES I RUBIO. THIRTEEN ZERO
OKAY ZERO THAT BILLS ON CALL ON
FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
TWELVE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL [inaudible]
WHAT'S SO [inaudible]
RUBIO. THIRTEEN ZERO OUR
CONSERVE BILLS ON CALL FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB SIX FIVE THREE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL [inaudible]
WHAT'S SO [inaudible]
RUBIO. THIRTEEN ZERO ON CALL.
TEENS ARE ON CALL NEXT BILL FILE
ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
FOUR MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU ELEVEN ZERO BRADFORD AB
MEMBERS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
WHY SO?
HILL I WHAT'S SO RUBIO. FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT'S OUT FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT'S OUT.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TEN THIRTEEN
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible]
OBSERVERS ALLEN [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL I WAS SO [inaudible]
RUBIO. THIRTEEN ZERO THAT'S OUT.
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
ELEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL I WAS SO [inaudible]
RUBIO. FOURTEEN ZERO THAT FILLS
OUT.FOURTEEN ZERO BILLS OUT
NEXT BILL [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
IT IS.
SHOP WITH ABOUT THE ITEM.
ONE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO OH
FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS BRADFORD [inaudible]
NIKON BACK [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE HILL.
HILL AYE WEST SO.
JONES JONES I RUBIO. THIRTEEN
ZERO IT'LL BE ON CALL.
WE CALL THE ROLL AGAIN
[inaudible]
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO OH FIVE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
CURRENT BOTH [inaudible]
THIRTEEN ZERO BRADFORD I
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT FILLS OUT.
YOU KNOWTHAT BILLS OUT.
EARLY ONES I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
SENATOR HOW ON THE FIRST
[inaudible] FOUR SEVEN THE
BUTTONS THAT.
CAN.
FILE ITEM TO AB TWO FOUR SEVEN
MOTION AS YOU PASS THROUGH
PERFORATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
BILLS OUT -- FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
ZERO LEVELS OUT.
FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTY FOUR TWO
NINE MOTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
HILL.
HILL I WAS SO [inaudible]
RUBIO. FOURTEEN ZERO THAT PULLS
OUT TWO ZERO THE BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM FOR EIGHTY FOUR SIX NINE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
THIRTEEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
RUBIO FOURTEEN ZERO THAT FILLS
OUT.
FILE BILLS OUT FILE ITEM FIVE A.
B. FOUR SEVEN SEVEN MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE PERFORATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS HILL.
I WAS SO RUBIO. FOURTEEN ZERO
ZERO THAT FILLS OUT FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB SIX FIVE THREE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS HILL.
HELL I'D WEST SO.
RUBIO FOURTEEN ZERO ZERO BILLS
OUT OF THAT -- CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS HILL.
HELLO I WAS SO RUBIO
[inaudible] FOURTEEN ZERO TWO
ONE FOR ME [inaudible]
BUT USER GET.
ON AT ALL. THIRTEEN ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
ANOTHER HARD.
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE MEETING
THIS MEETING IS ABOUT HER